Inserting the row, Madhya Pradesh, 28, 50.0, 60
into our aadhaar table would be allowed, despite the
fact that it's sort of gibberish. Madhya Pradesh's
size will be stored as 50.0 square kilometers and
it's population would be stored as 60. The
interesting thing here is that the capital would be
stored as 28, a string which doesn't really make
much sense. But, in any case, the data would
still be stored. You should always be careful to define the data
types for your columns in a sensible way. For example, storing numbers as
strings is problematic. Since it disallows
us from doing numerical computations on
the column. For example, taking the average value or finding the minimum value.